cbs news business analyst jill
schlesinger joins us now joe good
morning to you help me understand how we
can have 10 million job openings and 8.7
million unemployed wouldn't those
numbers cancel each other out
well look there's a lot of reasons why
people are still on the sidelines so yes
we've made great progress we have
recovered 16.7 million of the more than
22 million jobs lost during the pandemic
but that means there are 5.7 million
fewer jobs that are available and the
reasons that people cite for why they
remain on the sidelines are what we
heard in that piece we have child care
issues that are really difficult to
juggle there are people who live with
immunocompromised folks in their homes
so they've got health concerns and maybe
it's also this idea that the previous
industry that employed you is still in
flux so you put it all together and
there is a mismatch right now as you
noted i've heard from
hiring managers at restaurants in my
neighborhood i've heard from others
across the country talking about how
benefits from the government were so big
that they actually over-corrected people
were not going back to work because they
could sit on their couch and reap these
rewards is that true did that happen
that have an impact
well first of all we don't really have a
clear picture yet but what remember
those benefits were meant to do exactly
what they did we wanted people to stay
home because we wanted people to be safe
now there is some worry that perhaps
that that went on too long but right now
with the delta variant we don't have a
clear picture we do have some
information from the left-leaning
economic policy institute and they did a
look at what happened to employment in
states from april through the last month
where we have data which is july they
found the states that maintained federal
benefits those extra benefits actually
saw more job growth than the 26 states
that ended those benefits early so again
not all data in but that is an early
indication that the unemployment
benefits did not have a big role in this
very interesting okay so the federal
unemployment benefits are set to end uh
this month what should people who had
been receiving them
do
in their absence
well this is such a terrible gut check
moment and and what i'm hopeful about
when i talk to policy makers they too
feel this that when schools go back in
session as more people get vaccinated as
the variant starts to slow down that
we're going to have to have people go
back to work and look for jobs but look
it's a gut check moment if you are
losing those benefits you're going to
have to pound the pavement or pound the
computer screen and go look for one of
those job openings and you may have to
take a job that you don't like but
you've got to get money in the door and
that's most important for these families
yeah it sure is all right joe thank you
very much